la cirugía robótica es una operación
mínimamente invasiva realizada por
cirujanos que manipulan brazos robóticos
a través de varias incisiones diminutas
denominadas puertos
una máquina de cirugía robótica consta
de varios elementos principales como la
consola donde el cirujano se sienta
mientras realiza la operación
el carro ubicado al lado del paciente
que incluye cuatro brazos robóticos
interactivos conectados con instrumentos
quirúrgicos y sistemas de visión 3d de
alta definición
este sistema permite a los cirujanos
realizar movimientos precisos y
controlados en el cuerpo con una mayor
visión y destreza
durante la cirugía robótica
el cirujano insertará una cámara 3d de
alta definición a través de uno de los
puertos la cámara proporcionará una
vista ampliada de la zona quirúrgica
luego el cirujano insertará instrumentos
quirúrgicos especializados sostenidos
por los brazos robóticos restantes a
través de los otros puertos
sentado en la consola de la computadora
el cirujano observará el área quirúrgica
a través de un visor
y moverá los instrumentos quirúrgicos y
la cámara con controles similares a
palancas de mando y pedales
los movimientos del cirujano generarán
la entrada de datos informáticos para
guiar el movimiento de los brazos del
robot y de las herramientas quirúrgicas
algunas de las ventajas del sistema son
movimiento controlado y preciso de las
herramientas quirúrgicas
prevención de sacudidas o temblores
involuntarios de la mano
capacidad de funcionar en espacios más
pequeños a diferencia de la mano humana
mejor visibilidad de la zona quirúrgica
y menor pérdida de sangre y necesidad de
cicatrización en el paciente